when georgia's republican control senate
passed new voting laws the reaction was
scathing from civil rights activists and
democrats
this boycott is not something we want to
do
it's something we have to do they're
protesting the state's new rules
including limiting voting drop boxes and
new id requirements
citing the impact on minorities huge
corporations many based in the state
were initially muted
but after pressure came out in support
of activists saying voter access
is a fundamental right the most
consequential move came from major
league baseball
opting to move their all-star game out
of state
a decision that could cost georgia a
hundred million dollars
georgians and all americans should know
what this decision means
it means cancer culture and partisan
activists are coming for your business
they're coming for your game or event
in your hometown the masters golf
tournament
is going ahead the professional golf
association saying it's committed to
local charities in the community in
augusta
many star players say they support civil
rights but also the financial boost the
game brings
i think that's the topic that we should
all be talking about we shouldn't be
talking about whether we're here or not
um the masters the pga tour we do such a
good job and we're trying to help
communities out and i think that's
our main focus for the week beyond the
cause for corporations to condemn
georgia's voting laws
there's concern about the financial
impact some leading democrats in the
state say it's a fine line
but the potential to harm poorer
communities is very real
republicans say the new laws will make
georgia's elections more secure and have
walked back earlier rules that would
have limited voting
on sundays a major point of contention
democrats say corporations taking a
stand
is a move in the right direction it's
not cancel culture
when companies decide to stand up speak
their principles and values and
understand that their consumers are also
looking at what is happening here in
georgia
and that their consumers want to see the
company
do the right thing as well the new laws
are likely to face legal challenges even
as other states enact similar rules
it's likely the conservative leaning
supreme court will have the final say
as the battle for voting rights
continues andy gallacher
al jazeera